Today my toddlers wanted cereal for breakfast again,
so I decided to make some Cinnamon Toast Crunch
since that's my husband's favorite cereal
and the kids have never had it.
So I combine all of my dry ingredients into a bowl,
give that really good mix,
and then slowly add some oil and water.
I incorporate everything with my spatula
and then move on to using my hands.
Then I add in the cinnamon
and make sure it's incorporated
before putting my dough on some Parchment paper.
Use another sheet of Parchment paper on top
and roll it out as thin as I can.
Once it's rolled out,
I'm using a pizza cutter to just cut it into squares
or rectangles.
You can do it in whatever shape you want.
I ended up making two batches.
Sprinkled it with some sweetener.
You can use sugar.
I use mong fruit sweetener.
I put it on my Parchment paper
and baked in the oven at 3:50 for about 10 minutes
before I turned it down to 2:50
and baked it for another 35.
I pulled it out the oven,
let it cool,
and then broke the squares apart
before adding them to bowls with some milk.
This is now a favorite in our house.